uh thank you yes sir Anna is in the
studio with us and congratulations thank
you so much for the victory we are so
proud thank you so much I was like very
like nervous so today and I didn't
expect this opening and yeah at the
beginning probably would be happy with
the draw but
okay uh let's uh go through the game and
just at this night registered already
from at least it's a novelty okay the
entire idea I didn't see five right away
and you only Bishop B7 and Bishop A6
maybe I forgot something there's such
moves here five
yes I played Knight H3
yes yes so the idea is that if my knight
is still on F3 it's really like doing
nothing so idea may have been if she
wouldn't play H6 maybe like some ideas
F3 or
sometimes you can play three is three
yes and age six I'm not sure if it's the
right decision to take on F6 or not
well we analyzed it during the game it
was it was fine yes yeah then I realized
okay why it should be like worse that uh
like uh your structure slightly slightly
worse my pieces okay I have weakness on
cf4 and this three Square potentially
weak
Supply negative 4 here
now to 496 I was surprised that she
played very quickly I think here you
have to take your time and really
realize what kind of setup you want to
get Yes actually you're absolutely right
because now it's C6 is already a
slightly so yes wow well I can switch
the computer of course a little oh no
it's a six night H5 Rook d8 okay okay
to sacrifice this was also I was
thinking about Rook D sacrifice as well
then it simply goes for some active play
yeah
so
um here and okay speaking honestly after
Castle I missed one five six I'm not I'm
not sure if it's good or not but
you have six and I saw in some lines
this idea to play an H3 G4 but maybe H3
G4 it's like too slowly so I decided to
play like actively right away
this is a
yes it's the first line or whatever
no it's I was thinking
as you can see
the same idea okay
so uh I think that your position was
very good okay here I don't know I don't
know why I've taken G4
I think G3 is probably dubious move why
she could play probably instead of G3 or
B the move I calculated during the game
and I was worried about later on and and
I I don't know if you realize it yet but
you are about to well you won the
tournament wow
when I was living I was thinking here I
was not smiling I was thinking that if
it's dropped because like uh my mother
had feeling like slightly misplaced and
he she had to find couple exact moves
wow so you're very happy wow
unbelievable I cannot believe that so
this is probably your best achievements
yes and my chess career definitely like
the best in many years and the best
achievement actually I was thinking that
in any other sport you are allowed to
express your emotions but when you won
your game you know we saw a small or a
smile and then I was like I just I just
started very tired yeah and I'm still in
the game so when when are we going to
dance
Dance Play Chinese play table tennis
everything yeah yeah thank you like El
Mira and thank you everyone especially
like all the generations who are
supported here me who gave me motivation
and uh trying to prove that age age is
just a number maybe not but I'm very
happy and before this event I was
mentioned in my role models that most of
them were like older than me
okay so let's uh let's have a look at a
few critical moments here I wanted to
ask you because here you're clearly
better but actually I I I during the
game I I didn't know like for sure that
I'm better because then actually what
happened in the game that the computer
saw that
yes but I could not find that the best
continuation what should I do maybe your
idea and
um to end what well then you can take
take you can take and it's maybe just
give up the spawn on C4 no you should be
spiritually yes yeah I was thinking
about it I don't know why I didn't play
it actually even in the game uh that was
a very important Motif because if you
allow your your opponents well if to
take for example let's say after
um
calculator I told you yes and then if
you take I do not know what to do here
yes E3 but after E3 I didn't like Rook
g292 oh no no it's not here so it's not
here
anyway it was a very different important
defensive resource to have the Rook on
G4 and C4 yes yes so this is also some
little bit I don't know maybe I should
take on
Jacob sticks you've no not technology
First Take on C6 and play something here
with H4 which for that that's a little
bit not in a spirit of positions
yes but yes now yes
and I'm feeling that I'm missing
something during the game yeah
but anyway you were always yeah just
very awesome keeping the situation under
control I think it was always very
important so now and here Rook did of
course Rogue dieters was my first
temptation but after E5 Rook d8 yes
E5 a knife somewhere and
probably I'm still slightly better oh
but there's oh I'm at night oh 94 okay
yeah okay this I didn't see my
calculations yeah okay but let's get
back to the game because at some point
we were not sure if this ending was real
but this
okay
okay this is not winning but it's like
where I was very happy because nothing
too blunder I have a draw I have
perpetually I repeated this position
here I had about three minutes but in
such position you don't need much right
okay but after Rook H4 I think Bishop B3
was better right yes Bishop was better
so yeah but okay I need to try at least
I have Perpetual now right but uh tell
me here when you played Rook H4 uh well
did you have to convince yourself that
you have to play yes okay I I wanted to
I would be very happy draw with a draw
because it was very tense game a lot of
complication but here I realized okay if
I'm not playing for win here what's like
no risk to lose at all I couldn't give
Perpetual check any time I want and
maybe
she's not having good tournament and
yes you're absolutely right this is so
chance I didn't defend stumbling here so
she gave you I think I think like here
it was also instead of before there's
was it something better than before or
not oh maybe 97 also oh but maybe yes I
saw this but I uh after before she is
not obligated to take or what well there
was some unhuman variations no no before
before there is another variation
what's the difference well then you're
okay take away this position come on
this is not serious yeah
so yes and then we came to this thing
here was end game yeah no no sorry yes
that's the game no but okay it's three
slog the move actually I calculated also
1997 and E4 no no no no no no no no no
no no no one with Rooks on the board but
actually here did you calculate 97 yes
of course 1974 and Knight of six nights
of six uh you win the pound immediately
yes maybe but what's wrong with Israel I
think history is such a nice move I
don't know yeah nice and yes Sirens
analyzed your yeah maybe okay uh could
she move for Bishop on diagonal but I
think after
um she cannot explain Bishop G because
tonight
G7 and F6 it's not actually weak like
this so
yes yes this is not so clear wow
[Laughter]
yeah this I know even if computer says
it's draw it's probably not so easy of
course but that's like after a three our
hearts stop beating because we were
thinking that the position was
completely winning but then no I didn't
I didn't think it was winning yeah I
thought it was much better it was great
chances and I will play this game like
another is actually such a 50 moves yes
but now there is a clear past the
victory after E4 and you demonstrated
yes yes and I saw this in the game of
course yeah was very happy to and
calculated three times like
congratulations
next year
right I will do commentary and you will
pray
you have a deal yes it will also play
huge congratulations Anna one question
do you know that you also made the Grand
Master Norm uh okay I'm users are like
Amira already told me yesterday but are
you sure because as far by old rules I
know there is no GM Norm in eight rounds
it must be only a world team
championship or european Club cup but
only because of the players withdrawal
ah these are
oh this is very nice yeah yes
um
wow very happy I already mentioned who
became a GM around age of 40. so she's
like one of my role models and I want to
say hello to her and to thank everyone
who was rooting for me I want to thank
you Olga sagalchik I visit here in New
York it was such a wonderful atmosphere
as well and Rosa galitiani all my all
the
childhood friends with whom I played 20
years ago
first year's championship your poor
husband
why
I think like in this tournament he is
not poor
well this was okay I I already thank you
many times
well it's never enough to say I love you
uh anyway this was an absolutely
outstanding performance and
congratulations thank you
oh congratulations to be sure as Anna
zatonski is our 2023 Karen's Cup
champion with one around despair yes the
tournament will go on tomorrow it feels
like it's over but it's not it's not
over until it's over and Anna's taking a
handsome price one absolutely forty five
thousand dollars there's a Victor smile
there was ever one as Anna zutanski
takes clear first Seoul first
inspirational really the way she played
this tournament truly
truly
and the other two games that were still
running finish